with green just this more this afternoon
on this extraordinary day
as we welcome president joe biden back
to pittsburgh
you know mil19 is such a fitting
location
for president biden's address on
strengthening the national supply chain
and revitalizing u.s manufacturing
this iconic structure
represents both
the storied past
and the re-imagined future of american
manufacturing
decades ago
more than 5 000 workers
produce more than one
million tons of steel
per year right here at this site
helping to power pittsburgh
and the nation's economic engine
today mill 19 is where cmu and its
partners are catalyzing discoveries
in the essential components of the 21st
century manufacturing including robotics
3d printing advanced manufacturing and
artificial intelligence
it might seem
that the work taking place
here
is vastly different
from the work
of those who forge steel decades ago
yet i would offer to you
that in many ways
it's exactly the same
both are rooted
in deep pride
a tenacious work ethic
and the spirit of a community that's
helping to power a nation
mill 19 is also a showcase
for the power of public-private
partnerships
this building
and 178 acres that surround us
represent a remarkable alignment of
support and commitment
from civic
public and private leaders to advance
this region's renaissance and pursue new
approaches to community development
skills training
and education
at this inflection point for u.s
competitiveness
the nation is at the cost of building an
innovation-based economy through
historic investment
in our talent and workforce
in our research and development
enterprise and in our national
infrastructure
while this moment is powered by
technological innovations
it must also be driven
by our shared humanity and by a common
result to ensure that transformative
economic opportunities
reach all americans
i'm excited and grateful
to see so many elected officials and so
many community and foundation partners
here today
you are embracing this mission every day
through your service and through your
leadership
thank you for your commitment thank you
for your passion and once again welcome
to carnegie mellon
please welcomes
commerce
good afternoon
good afternoon before i make my remarks
i would just like to acknowledge
everybody impacted by this morning's
bridge tragedy and our thoughts and
prayers are with them and big thank you
to the first responders who did a
fantastic job
so when president biden called me to ask
me to take this job as secretary of
commerce he said
that one of his top priorities was
revitalizing american manufacturing
and that really resonated with me
because i'm from rhode island and my dad
worked his whole career in manufacturing
until when he was 56 years old the
factory closed the jobs went to china
and we were out
so i called my brother and i said hey
tom should i take this job and gina
that'd be so proud of you
if you are
manufacturing jobs to america
and that's what we're doing president
biden's top priority
is to make sure that we can compete
globally and he knows that means we have
to invest domestically
and thanks to his leadership this
economy is strong this economy is strong
by any measure
wages are up unemployment rate is down
created over six and a half million jobs
but the reality is even though the
economy is strong our supply chains are
very fragile and you know that
but the reason for that
is because for decades we've let all our
manufacturing jobs go overseas
and we haven't invested enough in
american manufacturing
that is particularly true
for semiconductors those tiny chips that
power everything
we are far too dependent on
countries
halfway across the world to get our
chips
that's an economic vulnerability and a
national security vulnerability and the
fact of the matter is and the president
says this all the time we can't have a
strong economy and a strong country
unless we get back into the business of
making things in america
[Applause]
right now right now there is a bill on
the floor of congress that would invest
52 billion dollars in domestic
semiconductor production and it would
create thousands of jobs all over
america
we need congress to pass that bill
in order to revitalize american
manufacturing revitalize american
semiconductor manufacturing it'll be a
win for our workers a win for our
businesses a win for our supply chains
and create thousands of jobs and we
can't wait so let's hope congress does
their job and gets the chips act to the
president's desk so i want to thank
thank you i want to thank the president
i want to thank the president for his
incredible leadership and for giving me
this opportunity to work with him to
revitalize and bring back great
manufacturing to america thank you
please welcome the governor of
pennsylvania tom wolfe
so thank you very much all of you for
being here this is really great to have
the president of the united states visit
pennsylvania actually there are two
really great reasons for him to be here
that we want to welcome first of all to
come back to his home state that's right
joe biden is a native pennsylvanian
and i hope you do but i know i take
credit for
president joe biden being the second
president of the united states who hails
from pennsylvania so we're proud of that
but i'm also proud that he's chosen
pittsburgh to come back and highlight
manufacturing pittsburgh is a story
about the resurrection of manufacturing
what we can do in this country if we
focus on investing in the things that
make manufacturing great that's what
made this place great in the first place
and it's making it great all over again
and its investment in the high tech
things that we saw today that's going on
at carnegie mellon university that was
really really important
let me point out one other thing i just
have a few comments before we came here
all of us toward
the forbes avenue bridge it collapsed
we need to invest in high-tech
manufacturing we need to make sure that
we bring manufacturing back to the
united states
and we need to invest and invest
directly in manufacture but we need to
invest in our infrastructure as well to
make sure that things like the forbes
avenue bridge don't happen
that was a real tragedy there's a
tragedy because people were hurt it was
a tragedy because a real thoroughfare in
pittsburgh was lost for a time
the commonwealth is working already to
put it back up but it's going to take
time
but it's a real tragedy because it could
have been prevented
had we done what we're doing here
investing in manufacturing had we
invested in our infrastructure we would
have been more productive because
bridges like that would not have fallen
down
so i applaud president biden for his
leadership not only in bringing
manufacturing back to the united states
places like pittsburgh but in trying to
make sure that we do what we've not done
for too long and that is invest in
infrastructure so thank you president
biden for coming to pennsylvania thank
you for your leadership and investing in
manufacturing and thank you for your
leadership investing in infrastructure
you are investing in the people of the
united states thank you very much
please welcome mayor ed gainey
good afternoon
i want to thank everybody for being here
today
and i definitely want to thank
president biden for coming to pittsburgh
today
it's a great day for a couple reasons
one we're celebrating a 1.2 trillion
bipartisan infrastructure law that will
help us repair our bridges our roads our
streets and connect people with good
paying union jobs we should celebrate
that from the beginning
[Applause]
and secondly let's really thank cmu
for doing order doing to just revamp
manufacturing in this region and thank
president biden for coming here and
investing in manufacturing in a way that
is going to prepare us to be victory in
the 21st century for that we are honored
and we definitely thank cmu and the
president for that amazing amazing feat
[Applause]
and thirdly let me say
i want to thank the president because he
pivoted
and came to the fern hollow bridge today
where we had a collapse of our bridge
and when we talk about investing in
infrastructure
when we're talking about how important
it is
for him to say i want to come and see it
myself
as the meredith city had made me feel
proud
that the president of the united states
had our back
and said that he would do whatever he
can to help us restore that bridge
so when we talk about infrastructure
dollars and how important infrastructure
is
that is a prime example why this bill is
so important we must invest in our
bridges in our streets because they are
the connector to our communities to our
schools to our jobs to medical facility
and that's why building infrastructure
like the ones we're talking about today
in manufacturing
that is what it's all about
and so today is a day of celebration
because as always when pittsburgh hits a
crisis we pull each other up and when we
pull each other up we build a better
city for everybody thank you
[Applause]
please welcome county executive rich
fitzgerald
thank you all for being here today
and especially thank you to president
biden
not just for what you're doing on the
1.2 trillion dollar infrastructure bill
but what you have done over the last
year
nothing short of spectacular
as secretary indicated six and a half
million jobs in one year
no president
in our history has created more jobs
in his first year
than this president has done we saw
yesterday the gdp
in the fourth quarter grew at
6.9 percent
numbers we never thought we would see
small businesses 30 percent increase
over the last year the highest in a
quarter century
the lowest unemployment forms
filed since 1969
1969 the pirates were played at forbes
field
steelers were playing at pitt stadium
ed gainey wasn't even born yet i don't
think mayor gaiman
but what's he doing for an encore
infrastructure nothing could have been
further from what we saw today than to
know the importance of infrastructure
and again
president after president democrat and
republican over the last number of
decades has tried to get an
infrastructure
bill passed
none of them were able to do it except
for president
again that's
[Applause]
that's and i want to thank our
congressional delegation for doing just
that
senator casey you're going to hear from
next
congressman doyle congressman lamb who
had the president's back
and worked together to make sure we
invest in our infrastructure
we needed this bill so badly we've
needed it for years and we need to be
proactive
and i know looking out into this crowd
we have a few steeler fans who
understand football
and in football
if your team
is in last place and only wins one or
two games
you fire the coach
we don't do that in pittsburgh because
our coaches do pretty well they learn
how to do that in cleveland and detroit
no i better not say that too loud in
front of people
but the last administration lost more
jobs
than any administration in our history
even more than herbert hoover
so what did we do we fired that coach
i'm not gonna even mention his name
and then we hired coach biden
and coach biden has done all those
things that i have talked about
and the other thing that coach biden has
done president biden has done is he has
not forgotten western pennsylvania he
continues to come here
he can he continues to come invest in us
and invest in our future and for that we
are very grateful
thank you president biden
please welcome senator bob casey
good afternoon i'm honored to be here
today as we all welcome back to
pennsylvania and back to pittsburgh
president biden
we're honored of course
by so many others today in this audience
and uh those who preceded me to the
microphone including
governor wolf
as well as our secretary of commerce
secretary raimondo
we want to pause today
of course to to remember what happened
uh just miles from here
we're thinking of those who were injured
today
in the bridge collapse
the collapse of that bridge over frick
park
we're thinking of those who are injured
but we're especially thinking
as well
of those who came to the rescue the
first responders
as usual
the city of pittsburgh the people of
pittsburgh came together in a crisis to
help those most in need let's give
first responders and local officials a
hand
[Applause]
i don't think i have to tell anyone here
the story of pittsburgh you know it
better than i do
but the story of pittsburgh
the story of allegheny county in
southwestern pennsylvania is a story
that president biden knows well
when he comes here in all the years he's
been
present here
walking in labor day parades shaking
hands and looking into the eyes of
people who struggle the working men and
women who are represented here today by
organized labor
he knows the story
of southwestern pennsylvania
the story of a people who were knocked
down
we lost a lot of jobs here
in the 70s and the 80s
but he also knows the story of how the
people of this region got back on their
feet
they worked
they innovated
and they invented
in fact they invented their own future
you can see it right here today in the
place that we stand
the good news about today and
more days ahead
is the president not only knows that
story
he's investing
in that future
and his work led to the investments we
can celebrate today
here at mill 19 this site
was once a home to a large steel mill
that employed more than 5 000 workers at
its peak
now it's up for advanced manufacturing
focused on robotics
artificial intelligence and so many
other innovations
the people of this city in this region
made it possible
mill 19 represents the best
of southwestern pennsylvania people
coming together and working with this
community here in hazelwood
a bright future
for the neighborhood and for this city
today children
who live just across the train tracks
can come to a former steel mill
and learn about robotics
and other skills in their neighborhood
at the same time we're grateful
that the president has made investments
in other parts of the economy of
southwestern pennsylvania
he sees firsthand and understands
the strength of our manufacturing
the
role in the new cloud
three rivers
those three rivers
those waterways drive this region's
economy while connecting our nation's
commerce all of this
is powered by men and women working day
after day to keep our supply chains
moving
and our commodities and our goods
moving across the country
but we know with waterways decades of
under investment put our waterways
infrastructure and the 76
500 jobs
in those waterways
we know that those
jobs are
now at risk if we don't make these
investments the good news is just a
couple of days ago
the army corps of engineers this
administration the biden and harris
biden harris administration announced
857.7
million dollars to complete the
construction of the montgomery block and
dam we're grateful for that
[Applause]
and so this is a day
to look towards that future
the future for young children
in this neighborhood in this city this
county
in this region
today is a day
to focus on tomorrow
and we're grateful that you're here with
us to do that and thank you again to
president biden for taking the time to
be with us today and we look forward to
hearing from him shortly
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
please welcome the president of the
united states joe biden accompanied by
jojo burgess
[Music]
jojo burgess and a proud member of the
united steelworkers
local 1557.
i've worked at u.s steel for three years
not a declarative plant but i have over
23 years union experience with the steel
workers
i'm also the son
of two former steel workers and i'm
proud to announce also that my son is a
third generation steel worker working in
the pittsburgh area
i can't tell you how exciting honored i
am to be part of this event that
highlights me
manufacturing in this pittsburgh area
but the entire state of pennsylvania
benefits from this
a big part of my job that u.s steel is
training new hires to work on
the coke batteries which is a vital
process involved in the still making uh
process
i'm glad that i'll be able to go and say
to the leadership of president biden to
those new hires
that not only your job's safe for today
but he's investing in your jobs in the
future
that's big for me
also i'm a veteran a desert storm
veteran
i can go to my fellow veterans and say
listen
this president is invested in us also
by making sure that there are jobs
available for veterans coming back into
society to be part of
this
growing economy
and
manufacturing boom excuse me sorry
so i'm beyond grateful to uh
president obama for his leadership in
getting the investment jobs act passed
it was a victory that was long overdue
and this manufacturer in this country
will benefit from it so again thank you
mr president
the investment bill makes in industries
like mine and steel
very very important again in this
country
i have to talk about this pittsburgh
region because again i say i have 23
years experience in manufacturing in
this region
uh i'm going to pause a second again
like the others didn't talk about the
infrastructure and what happened today
in the city of pittsburgh
my thoughts and prayers with all the
people that were affected by that but i
have to
admit
this region the pittsburgh region
benefits from this act for several
reasons i can look at my experience down
at u.s steel everyone hears steal but
one thing that they don't know is
partner infrastructure
comes out of our edgar thompson plant
the slag that is used there is used in
the
paving of roads and helping to help the
infrastructure in commerce and getting
trucks and stuff across this country
also when we talk about the still
workers supplying america
that's no lie just right here in
southwestern pennsylvania
i could think about the different locals
and the different people that i've
worked with come in contact with
the local down in canonsburg where we do
our pots and pans
uh world-renowned uh all-clad medals
my son works at a place called
international paper we box the stuff
that we got to ship around this country
for people to be able to move their
goods
a place that i worked at for years
pennsylvania transformer they make power
transformers that deal with the
infrastructure providing electricity to
this country
so again
we we appreciate all that this
president's leadership has done to bring
manufacturing back to this area
so it's now
now it is my utmost privilege to
introduce a man who has made it a point
to be a champion for workers
for unions and for a generation to come
president joe biden
please sit down
please please sit down jojo thank you
very much
you know i can picture him in desert
storm as a sergeant barking out orders
can't you
when my son beau
promoted to major
in uh
in iraq and i said now you're a field
grade officer
he said that i have no illusions i know
who runs the army sergeants
sergeants they're the officers
well hello pittsburgh it's good to be
back it really is going to be before i
begin
let me just talk a little bit about what
we all just saw many of us saw this
morning
a bridge more than 50 years old 100 i
think it was 150 years says 50 years old
but i thought it was older
collapsed right here in pittsburgh
it had been rated in poor condition for
the past 10 years
what you all know if you don't you
should know there are another 3
300 bridges here in pennsylvania with
some of which are just as old and just
as
decrepit
condition as that bridge was
including here
in pittsburgh the city of bridges i've
been coming to pittsburgh a long time
i'm a pennsylvania kid i was born and
raised the first part of my life in
pennsylvania and i've been to pittsburgh
a lot
but all these years i never knew
i never knew pennsylvania
pittsburgh pennsylvania had more bridges
than any other city in the world yo
but across the country there are 45 000
bridges in poor condition
it's just simply unacceptable
that's why your governor and your
members of congress your mayor have been
saying for years we have to do something
about this i've talked about it every
time i've come to pittsburgh
and we finally got it done
a bipartisan infrastructure law
including the largest investment in our
nation's bridges since the
since the eisenhower put together the
interstate highway system and i might
add
this is the first time in the country's
history that we dedicated
national program to repair and upgrade
bridges it's about time
the governor can tell you
we're giving state and local leaders
historic funding to make national
projects real here in pennsylvania that
means at least 1.6 billion dollars for
bridges alone
327 million
in 2022 alone just to repair bridges
we've got to get it on with it we got to
move
the next time we don't need headlines
saying that someone was killed when the
next bridge collapsed
we're also providing billions more for
roads and so much more
we saw today when the bridge is a
disrepair it literally can threaten
lives
as soon as we heard about the bridge we
were immediately in contact with the
mayor mr mary doing a hell of a job and
the governor and other officials on the
ground
and we're going to rebuild that bridge
along with thousands of other bridges in
pennsylvania and across the country
because it's in our interest for our own
safety sake
and it generates commerce in a way that
we can't do now
that's part of how we're going to build
a better america and that's what i want
to talk to you about today
so thank you for the introduction jojo
mayor mr mayor county executive rich
fitzgerald great to see you again pal
and it's good to be here with so many
outstanding folks particularly the
governor lieutenant governor john
fetterman
john i i had you in front of me when i
was playing at delaware i could have
been an all-american it could have been
big
but uh but and conor lambs great to see
you man
and you're doing a hell of a job all of
you my good friend
and former neighbor and scranton bobby
casey now his dad we're we're about the
same spread his dad was much older than
me than i am than bobby but we lived i
lived in north washington avenue you
notice they changed the end of the road
name it's the joe biden way now
you know no you see that
i shouldn't say this i'm gonna get in
trouble in delaware mr secretary but uh
the first thing i asked uh the election
results i said how did i do in scranton
i want every precinct
and
so i used to drive up
route 81 all the time
to get not just to get scranton but get
up to syracuse when i was at syracuse
law school
and uh and now the entrance to go get to
scranton off 81
is the joe biden expressway
so i'm coming home bobby i'm coming home
look
all kidding aside
i want to thank our commerce secretary
former governor junior raimondo for
joining us today and i want to thank
congressman mike doyle couldn't be here
today but who's done so much for this
district
nearly three years ago i began my
campaign for president right here in
pittsburgh first major stop i made
i said back
i said back then i was running to
restore the backbone of america the
middle class
it's time we began to build this country
from the middle up and the bottom out so
that we i've never known when a wealthy
person didn't do well when the middle
class was doing well we always do better
when ordinary hard-working people have a
shot
after i accepted the party's nomination
in august of 2020 i came to mill 19 for
my first major campaign
and i laid out my vision to build a
better america
with better pay greater dignity for the
working people who are the ones who
built this country i often hear about
how who built the country guess what
the middle class built this country and
unions built the middle class
and folks
[Applause]
making it in america with american
manufacturing
and easing the financial burdens on
millions of families
that's the same vision i laid out once
again when i was here in pittsburgh when
i was the first stop i made after i was
sworn in as president
now after my first year i wanted to come
back to pittsburgh this is my third time
here in this facility to take stock of
what we've accomplished together and
look forward to the extraordinary
opportunities that lie ahead for
pittsburgh and america if we continue to
do our job
from day one
every action i've taken to rebuild the
economy has been guided by one principle
make it in america like we used to
no one knows that better than all the
folks here in pittsburgh and that's why
it matters so much
making in america
is what built this city the steel city
the arsenal democracy during world war
ii when pennsylvania generated as much
steel as germany japan and italy
combined
right here in the city of pittsburgh but
pittsburgh also knows the consequences
when we ignore the backbone and fail to
invest in ourselves fail to invest in
our people
some of you have been
around long enough to remember how this
city lost 100 000 steel jobs between
1970 and 1990.
i was raised when i moved from scranton
my dad didn't have any work and we moved
to clemont delaware used to be an outfit
called worth steel
for over 6 000 still the town was a
company town
there's not a single steel worker there
now
by the 1980s
more than three quarters of pittsburgh
steel capacity had been shuttered
you or your parents remember what you
felt like in your neighborhood it didn't
feel good
the painful ripple effect it had
jobs lost families ripped apart
so you know that to build a truly strong
economy we need a future that's made in
america
that means using products parts
materials
built right here in the united states of
america
it means bringing manufacturing back
jobs back building the supply chains
here at home
not outsourcing abroad so we have better
jobs and lower prices here
it means betting on america's workers
and it takes the federal government that
doesn't just give lip service to buying
america but actually takes action
that's the approach i've taken from day
one
and now
we're beginning to see the results
we learned this week after my first year
as president the united states had the
fastest economic growth in nearly four
decades
along with
[Applause]
along with the greatest year of job
growth in american history 6.4
million jobs created in one year
and instead
of losing manufacturing jobs since
they've been office america has actually
added an additional
367 000 manufacturing jobs in america
good paying jobs
the highest increase in u.s
manufacturing jobs in 30 years
and last week
the ceo of intel
pat
gelsinger came to the white house
because he wanted to support the bill
back better initiative and to also let
me know two of your neighboring senators
were here
were there portman and brown
a democrat and republican from ohio he
came to announce a new 20 billion dollar
semiconductor campus outside of columbus
ohio that's going to create 10
000 jobs
7 000 constructing the facility and 3
000 permanent jobs and by the way i was
joking i said i may need a job he said
well it's not bad the average salary is
135 000 a year
folks
and the key is these jobs are
manufacturing essential products stamped
made in america
semiconductors are though you all know
they're small computer chips that power
virtually everything in everyday life
and they were originated here in the
united states of america we used to own
not only the patent but the technology
and the production
your phone your car your refrigerator
your washing machine
hospital equipment the internet the
electric grid and so much more depend on
these chips
so this is going to create thousands of
additional jobs helping build more
american products for example
you know
inflation is a problem which i'll speak
to in a second that's real a lot of
people are being hurt by it but guess
what
one third
of the inflation in america is a
consequence of the cost of automobiles
one third
you know why
because of the shortage of
semiconductors
they can't build them
and therefore the ones that aren't being
built caused the price of those r being
built to go much higher
this announcement helps fix that problem
three days ago
i called a meeting in the white house
of ceos from general motors ford
microsoft euler packard and others
mary bearer
general motors ceo
announced in the white house initial 7
billion investment in michigan to
manufacture electric vehicles
creating 4 000 new quality jobs
that's on top of the announcement made
by ceo ford jim farley last year
investing 11 billion dollars
in electric vehicles creating 11 000
new jobs and today right here in western
pennsylvania
the union pacific railroad is announcing
the largest purchase of american-made
battery electric locomotives in all of
history by the way
guess who's supplying those batteries
general motors
folks
i want to tell you it matters it matters
a lot
the company will build these locomotives
called
webtech
wab in their name is because they grew
out of the old westinghouse air brake
company a classic pittsburgh
manufacturer
lab tech is based here in pittsburgh
and these locomotives will be built up
in erie it's the same plant that thomas
edison built the general electrics more
for general electric more than a century
ago
not only will these locomotives be
running here at home powering our
economy and decreasing pollution
webtech will also be exporting them to
canada to australia and all around the
world again creating more good paying
jobs
folks
in the process
reducing climate change generating jobs
here in western pennsylvania
as i said good paying jobs you can raise
the family on
my dad said that all you need
a family needs just a little bit of
breathing
a little bit of breathing room
and so many people don't have it now
it also means something else
means that right here in pittsburgh the
future is being built on the foundation
of this city's storied past
an announcement like this doesn't happen
in a vacuum
the manufacturing resurgence we're
seeing today is no accident
it takes local leaders
federal leaders foundations businesses
unions universities
all pulling together
requires a mindset
like you have here in mil-19
here's what i mean by that
generations ago mil19 used to roll out
10 inch steel bars
today it rolls out the latest innovation
in advanced manufacturing robotics
3d printing and artificial intelligence
it's simply rolling out the future
that's what it's going to be doing
that success is real of a partner a
result of a partnership
the federal government provides funding
from everything from basic research to
great universities like carnegie mellon
to supporting partnerships that help
small business in western pennsylvania
get into the game in the first place
like the businesses here at mill 19.
organizations
like one called catalyst
they work with small businesses to adapt
the latest technologies they need and
grow and grow and compete globally
the work the work is made possible by
funding from the commerce department
and they partner with engineers and
researchers from carnegie mellon
university who designed the next
generation of advanced manufacturing
equipment
creating technologies that work
alongside workers instead of replacing
the workers
in fact
carnegie mellon and the f and the
afl-cio are
pleased to make sure their
support work
my
arm
it is a
public
government
so
right
here i'm good
[Music]
billion dollars
spent in regional economies throughout
the country
some of that money is coming right here
to western pennsylvania
in support of efforts that include
partners here at mill
19.
helping spread new robotics artificial
intelligence manufacturing technologies
and create more jobs across the nation
look you all get it the bottom line is
this
it takes all of us working together all
of us working together to get this done
and that's finally beginning to happen
when the federal government invests in
innovation
it powers up the private sector to do
what it does best
creating incredible new technologies new
industries most importantly new jobs
good paying jobs
these are the kinds of investments and
partnerships
that help us build a made in america
future
we can't slow down now
we can't slow down now we know what
happens when we stop investing
in the future
of places like pittsburgh
decades ago
we used to invest two percent
of our gross domestic product in
research and development here in america
let me emphasize that research and
development
today
we invest less than one percent
the united states of america used to be
ranked number one in the world
in investing in the future
now we rank number nine
in research and development
china was number eight
three decades ago
today it's number two
and other countries are catching up fast
but we can and we must change that
trajectory
we have an opportunity ahead of us right
now the house and senate
the united states congress the united
states
senate are working out a bill
that's going to provide an extra 90
billion dollars for research and
development
manufacturing all the elements of the
supply chain need to produce the end
products
this should help create more
partnerships like the ones you have
right here in mill 19.
secretary armando former governor of
rhode island
she's been helping lead this effort
she knows what it takes
and my expectation is this will continue
to be a bipartisan effort god willing
just like the infrastructure law
and by the way
regarding the infrastructure law
we brought together democrats and
republicans
being led by senator casey and senator
lamb and other members of your
delegation democrats
along with republicans
to do something about infrastructure
now just 74 days after signing that law
we're already making tangible
differences
for highways ports airports rail
high-speed internet clean air clean
water
that includes 1.6 billion dollars
over the next
five years for pennsylvania to repair
its bridges
as i said earlier the more than three
thousand three hundred bridges
across pennsylvania and over seven
thousand five hundred miles of highway
poor condition
it also means jobs replacing lead water
pipes
so
you can drink clean water not lead-based
[Applause]
everywhere in america
so the kid could use his computer or her
computer to be able to tie into the
internet
out of the mcdonald's or any other fast
food restaurant
this is the united states of america for
god's sake
what are we doing
what in god's name are we doing
we've announced major investment
of 500 excuse me 858
million dollars
to modernize the montgomery lock in
northwest of pittsburgh
the waters or stay high enough for
barges to pass through of the upper ohio
river
we move about a half a trillion dollars
worth of goods through those locks
like these across the country every
single year
when we're not when they're not working
it creates choke points
barges break up goods don't get to where
they need to go
bob casey's been on my back about this
for so long
as we get this montgomery lock project
done i think we should call it the casey
lock i mean
[Applause]
bobby i didn't know anybody in scranton
knew what the hell the lock was you know
what i mean
but all kidding aside
it's going to happen
it's going to happen
i've also announced after consulting
with my friend cecil roberts president
of my worker
plan to cap and plug orphan gas wells
and oil wells skewing methane into the
air
over a hundred thousand
clean up abandoned mines
i come from coal country scranton
thousands of these wells helped generate
economic growth here in pennsylvania
but now it's time to create good paying
union jobs capping those roads
we're abandoning
they get the same salary as those who
dug them in the first place
look
this law also delivers 7.5 billion
dollars to build a network of electric
vehicle charging stations
good friend of mine lonnie stevenson the
president ibw
they're gonna have a good time man
five over 500 000
of these charging stations on our
highways
and by the way when you build these
stations
what happens is like when you build a
gas station on the highway
other things go around it
you're going to see communities grow as
a consequence making this more globally
competitive in the future of electric
vehicles while helping fight climate
change
and folks here in pennsylvania you all
know best
the cost of inaction
when it comes to climate
extreme weather cost this state
10 billion over the last decade 10
billion
you all remember last fall when
hurricane ida made landfall
and
he's
running my operation now
in the
former maryland louisiana
when it hit louisiana
winds hit 178 miles an hour
guess what happened here
it flooded businesses in oakdale homes
in millvale
nationally last year extreme weather
cost us
145
billion dollars
as it'll cost the american public
the extreme weather is not going to ease
up on its own
we have to be ready
that's why we're investing in our
resilience
building roads higher when we rebuild
them
our levees stronger
our power grids more
durable so they don't get blown down and
cause
massive massive massive wildfires
to withstand the increasing ferocity of
extreme weather
you know i went all over the country
last year
visiting these sites
flying over vast vast stretches of land
in the west in oregon washington idaho
looking down from that helicopter seeing
nothing but
barren
barren land
you know more
timber more housing more businesses
burned to the ground
last year in the united states than the
entire
physical size of the state of new jersey
from the new york state line
down to the delaware bay
that's how much burger about this last
year
all of these investments
in making an american research and
development infrastructure really about
one thing
empowering more cities and more towns
to do what you're doing right here in
pittsburgh
transforming yourself
from being told you're a city without a
future to becoming the city of the
future
i think what think what your kids are
going to have
with this leadership you have in front
of you here
15 years from now here in pittsburgh
we're going to lead the world again it's
not hyperbole
it's a fact
where instead of shuttering factories
along the alligator river
we're going to now talk about not steel
world we're going to talk about robotics
row
three mile run was some of the world's
most innovative businesses
a place
being written
where families can have good paychecks
good homes
a future
it's a little bit of breathing room
the story we have kept writing here in
pittsburgh you keep writing communities
all across the country is the one you've
begun
but we can't slow down folks
we need to ease the burden on working
families make you think everything
everything more affordable and
accessible the hard-working people
that's why my buildback better plan is
all about
that's why those major corporations came
to the white house asking to see me to
tell me they supported build back better
even though it was going to increase
their taxes
going to increase their taxes
this plan will not cost the american
people a single penny beyond no one
making less than four hundred thousand
dollars will pay a single additional
penny in their taxes that's a and it
reduces
the deficit
and fourteen nobel laureates and
economics wrote to me telling me
that would also diminish the impact of
inflation
take child care
how many families
in this town can continue to afford to
pay 14 000 per kid for child care
well the plan i have cuts that in half
for most families helping them
helping with their budgets helping
millions of parents especially women go
back to work
how many of you know anybody
who has type 1 diabetes
they need insulin
how much it costs to make that insulin
less than ten dollars
you know how much it costs on average
nationwide
for a monthly supply of insulin which
you need every single month
656 dollars as high as a thousand
dollars
imagine being the parent
making the minimum wage or twice the
minimum wage
and having a child with type 1 diabetes
knowing that if you can't and have no
insurance
knowing if you cannot get
that money for the insulin your child
might die
in addition to your child
it strips you of your dignity damn it
can you imagine looking at your child
and you know
what they need
and not be able to do it
many of you have lost children
many of you have seen
imagine
it's outrageous
we have an answer
at the same time
same is true
for home and community-based services
for seniors and people with
disabilities folks look
[Applause]
what's the one thing if you know
a lot of you are part of the so-called
sandwich generation
you have a child
and you need to get day care so you can
go out and work
as well as you got a mom or a dad
who's elderly
and living at home and they don't want
to move out of their house
they don't have to sell every single
thing they have to be able to move into
a nursing home
but you know
the data shows
88 000 people qualify 800 000 people
qualify under medicare to get that help
but it's not available
and sometimes just as little as making
sure there's someone there just to pick
up the prescription
put a handrail in the shower
making sure someone can show up
and help the meal
it's cheaper for everybody
it's a decent thing to do
because the parents deserve to have a
little bit of dignity
it will not cause will not increase the
deficit
it will not cost anybody making less
than four grand 400 000 bucks
a penny
i'm a capitalist if you can make a
billion dollars a million dollars go at
it it's good
at least pay a little bit
fortune 500 companies
and fortune 500 companies the last two
years there are 55 who made over 40
billion dollars
didn't pay a cent in taxes
i'm not talking about anybody paying any
more than they did
10 years ago
look
see the
we know how to ease the pressure on
families
we're increasing productivity
and the potential for
we can afford these investments by
making sure the wealth is just pay a
little bit
without increasing the deficit
as i said no one earned a lesson i
guarantee you check it out no one
learning less than 400 grand
will ever pay another penny
i told you about the impact of
17 nobel laureate saying it's going to
decrease inflation not increase it
here's the bottom line
the united states is in a position to
out-compete the rest of the world once
again
we're at a real inflection
point technology
society's changing
and we've always been ahead of the curve
we have an incredible opportunity
we still face tremendous challenges
if we keep coming together and invest in
the backbone of this country
there's no limit to what we can achieve
so let's continue
continue to give working families a
fighting chance
let's keep investing in the future
of every city and town in this country
let's face the challenges head on
let's keep building a better america
because it's totally completely within
our
i push it
time we stop fighting
it's about time we start working
together again
thank you for your consideration for
what we're talking about
you can do an awful lot
thank you thank you
folks
a guy who's helping all those vets
coming back
is the head of the va dennis mcdonough
spread your hand pal
let him know who you are i he's back
anyway
we'll get him
we'll we'll get him there's a lot going
on folks
god bless y'all may god protect our
troops thank you
[Music]
now
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
it